our sponsor for this episode is element
drink max it's a tasty electrolyte drink
mix with everything you need no sugar
nothing artificial no [ __ ] i am an
athlete so i depend on my electrolytes i
train hard so i lose a lot of sodium up
to seven grams per day if i don't get
that back i can get really tired even if
you don't train hard like me the baddest
[ __ ] on the planet everyone
still needs their electrolytes you can
get headaches and muscle cramps if you
don't hydrate properly anybody can try
it risk-free
there's a money-back guarantee no
questions asked it's used by so many
badasses around the world just like me
anybody wants it badass all they have to
do is go to drinkelement.com
for their free sample pack now
think this [ __ ]
please
drink element i mean i [ __ ] took the
edibles on the plane over here i had no
idea where i was for five hours i took
like 300 milligrams over
i didn't know i was flying or [ __ ]
sitting still
how many um
insurance we do
well not last night normally when we do
the show
that'll have my jaw
[Music]
moving and gentlemen i'm mike tyson
another episode of hot boxing and i got
my man the one other chef
consort
action promise hell yeah what's up
another time
listen brother i want to know something
about your your cooking skills and i've
been hearing a lot about you i'm telling
you if we had something here i would've
you know i've been practicing i made
some steak last night
i you know i went crazy this morning i
like making snacks like i just meal
prepped yeah i'm out here i'm trying to
eat i'm trying to stay i'm trying to
stay you know
february
i need are you real i've been trying
i've been trying to be on me but it
doesn't doesn't really make me feel good
regular meat made me feel better but
i've i've done everything i feel like
when i stop eating red meat sometimes i
feel better but then when i get back on
i feel stronger i can't dial it in let's
i go through state like listen i go for
two months exactly again yes and then i
go two months me though just a little
very little bit of meat you know
yeah i've just been gotta fluctuate you
can't stay cause if you're not if you're
taking away something you need you gotta
replay through with something sure
so i mean that's just where i've been
man i've been trying to do everything i
can to just stay on top of the health
you know not eat out too much
never eat out yeah i mean you know it's
[ __ ]
getting the only time i get a weight
problem when i go to new york city
that's the only city i eat in yeah
that's where the hell i'm at i'm there
every single day but you know i'm
utilizing the bike i'm riding on the
bridges and running on the list when i'm
in new york i don't eat the way i
normally eat like kid when i'm in new
york i gotta
go crazy i might eat a kanesh with
ketchup on it
uh one of those nasty brooklyn pizzas um
a conditional ketchup is [ __ ] low-key
one of the most amazing things just to
get them from the little truck a little
hot dog
poor people food it wasn't delicacy yeah
you're right
it's a nice uh jewish job you can see
[ __ ] ganesh it's a good i mean i
learned about conditions when i was a
[ __ ] kid from my grandfather
my grandfather's from brownsville yes he
grew up on the street
another thing mark you know
yeah he was actually
um jack dempsey was his upstairs
neighbor they were good friends yeah
yeah
how do you say mr dempsey was
i don't know who was good friends they
were yeah they were he came to us you
know to his wedding it was a beautiful
thing they had a good friendship
he had a picture with him yes
he left me like when he died he left me
all his bare knuckle pictures yeah all
the boxers talked to him before of
course who jack dempsey yeah no no my
grandfather did you talked to him no no
imagine that
no but i got all the knowledge from my
grandfather he had all the boxing
pictures all over since i was a kid
so we always got you know a lot of
pleasure watching you thank you you know
growing up growing up that way that's
how we were connected you know i always
was a big fan of jack dempsey because um
from a psychological perspective he was
the first fighter that admit that he was
afraid mm-hmm you know most fighters
don't admit they're afraid that's just
that's their ego i'm not in
absolutely if you have to be if you have
to be brave what what do you have to be
pray for you're afraid you're right no
and that's what makes you react the way
you are right no doubt about it
those reactions yeah you get [ __ ]
scared shitless you fight for your life
for you exactly that's how i always
thought about it this is this is the big
show this is the last one this is not
when i lose this one it's over so i'll
give it all i have i'll leave it all out
there every time leave it all out every
[ __ ] time man i i've realized i want
to drain my soul
of all its potential now like whatever i
have now in this life
i want to get the most out of everything
i'm done with [ __ ] half-assing [ __ ]
lying about dumb [ __ ] just
i'm trying you know i'm i'm right about
that level two i'm reaching that level
too keeping it real myself about it i
hate myself it makes me feel like you
yeah tell everybody the truth by a lot
of myself
you look in the mirror you're [ __ ]
around with yourself exactly it's like
playing a little game so what you up
doing man what you into man what's been
going on lately what am i into i'm into
all kinds of things i've been in the
water a lot in the ocean
i'm really into
into riding the waves man how far are
you going oh you're in this um
yeah yeah in the bodyboard
bodyboard what's that like man it's
it's like flying it's like [ __ ]
superman it's like you're just flying
through the air but you're on water and
it's just
you're seeing the the wave curl right in
front of your face and somehow you're in
you're in it
now what happened tell me what happens
when that it's like a vortex it's
exactly a vortex it's like work it's
like when you hit the dmt and you blast
off it's that sound of silence and then
that's just it's like euphoria
it's like man i can't believe i'm
[ __ ]
i'm taming this natural element like
this
i'm not great but you know
when it happens it's like next [ __ ]
what's the longer the person staying on
the board before whatever without
falling i mean the rides aren't that
long probably like 15 seconds the most
but you see
but you see these dudes they're like the
pros they could just keep going it's all
about you know reading the way you know
when you catch different it's it's
[ __ ]
you have to be a weatherman a meteor man
you have to be able to read the ocean
takes it takes a while
takes a while but it's a beautiful thing
i like to connect with earth
you know i had to experience the um
dive with sharks
and i had to put one to sleep
really shark week yeah upside down yeah
it was just when they were just like
chilling well yeah it was catatonic yeah
but that was a really um
a really challenging moment for me
because i don't i don't [ __ ] with water
like that
life-changing though right
and it's very humbling
and the water is like you know 30 feet
high and you're like whoa i'm down here
to all these i'm just out of my element
i can't move fast enough i'm in the iron
suit little nettle i'm dead yeah no that
that there's
there's so much life underneath that
underneath that [ __ ] water you know
more about this
hey listen we know more about the sky
that we know about the water 100
something because you can't get to those
depths
they crush you
easily and and the biggest monsters in
the world at the bottom and they can't
come up because of the pressure bust
their lungs that's right and they're
normally blind they have tentacles yep
yeah i mean i've seen some of these
these documentaries where there's like
[ __ ] translucent fish and just like
straight up electrical charge looking
things um invisible looking yeah yeah
exactly invisible you see is this
sometimes it was um i don't know what
was the gentleman name
well anyway he had that he went to the
bottom of the ocean he saw extinct
fishes the extinction in that little pod
right yeah that's yo so these fish are
extinct but they're at the bottom of the
ocean
yo uh like the the straight in between
gibraltar like the strait of gibraltar
it's apparently like unbelievably deep
and you send that [ __ ] down there
seven foot seven seven seven miles i
it's something like that because i saw
one when it went down was i don't know
seven miles and then it was a big hole
in the vehicles
what the [ __ ] knows what the hell
that's the abyss
hates the hell exactly yeah
it's just creepy when you see the bottom
of the ocean then you see up at the
bottom of the ocean there's a big black
hole which is
and the bottom is black with a big light
and then if you go right there you can't
even see the light is so black and dense
you know i'm saying what kind of
monsters are on the map they mention if
you got out there grab it so fast before
you even know it
you know that ain't a bad way to go you
know what i mean
quick and easy
kind of a [ __ ] you know
it's a that's glorious kind of you know
like it's a rare death well nothing's
gloriable but quick and easy now you're
right yeah you're right you gotta fight
you're right you're right you gotta
suffer
yeah
you ever been to tulum like in mexico or
the cenotes and [ __ ] like that
no i've been on the whole underground
like
mexico city
um i really like mexico guatemala
i like that place i love the people for
real they're
beautiful people incredible right but
the cenotes they're like these
underground
like
like humongous cathedrals of water you
know what i mean they're just like pools
of fresh
gorgeous water that somehow connect
into the ocean through these underground
passages like that have been eroded over
millions of [ __ ] years and you could
dive through them and go through these
caverns and [ __ ] i've done that in um
spain bro it's unfucking i leave it in
spain scuba diving yeah it's crazy [ __ ]
yeah it's [ __ ] crazy and the cave
went the cave yeah
you just chill in the cave that water
touches your skin it's like
you replenish you cm the fish come right
through your big fish
that's the chip down
right by [ __ ] between your legs these
monsters pike looking station
they look like monsters with big teeth
but they're wimps yeah nah they just
chill they're just looking for some
plankton that was a good experience for
me i went from ibiza spain to the
ukraine and then i took a plane to
moscow i like i like mushrooms oh i
[ __ ] like russian man it's a crazy
place no it's crazy good though yeah in
a good way oh you don't have no stress
or problem don't gotta worry about
people [ __ ] with you you do something
you can [ __ ] jaywalk
damn it's extravagant
everything's expensive there yeah
that's probably the number one place in
the world that was uh to buy the most
money all those guys i never been out
there never been to you can't you can't
smoke weed and [ __ ] like that they'll
[ __ ] catch me up by the way yeah you
could drink it you know yeah that's a
trip right you catching up
i met like i remember in new york man
you [ __ ] had to put the weed under
your nuts and [ __ ] and have to be scared
for a [ __ ] nickel bag of weed they'll
[ __ ]
yeah like and everyone's if you just
walk around with the [ __ ] bong in the
street now well they they said that
because you know marijuana that means
mexican cigarettes
that's why they wanted to attach it to
the mexicans and the blacks and the
entertainers and stuff and just and have
a reason to [ __ ] with people i forgot
this guy's al singer he he in 1937 he
made they made a movie called reefer
madness i showed up yeah they smoke
grief and lost it they went to the mad
house one way to take it to the mad
house
put him in a loony bin yeah he was a
serious after
that
i want you
they didn't try any of that other [ __ ]
yet they didn't try the lsd and all that
oh that good stuff listen that's what's
part of that was my medicine yesterday
a little bit uh
it was an lsd mix and
some um psychedelics beautiful
i was doing this little festival
yesterday like some weed [ __ ] and
somebody in the crowd gifted me
a little pot of peyote
i've never done that yet me neither i'm
waiting but now
you know it has to grow
like a little baby
now i gave it to my boy who's like one
of the best growers in the world to grow
this thing um when it when it buds i'm
calling you i would love to do it yeah
it's going down this is a little this is
our movie team look at that tv team oh
this is beautiful man
got your own little private area this is
like i even trained here still talking
[ __ ] you need this is all you need
to [ __ ] live in the back yeah they
have three offices all down the block we
don't need to just need a kitchen in
here so i could get one wanted to talk
or you get a little weber could make
magic on that what's that a little
[ __ ] grill pot yeah you never get old
potty little grill
go to whole foods get it crazy
and let's line up some [ __ ] about
bronzers
i'll give you a [ __ ] synopsis i was
mad fat i lost mad weight i've been
rapping and [ __ ] i used to be a chef i
still am
buster
[ __ ] yo
yo yo yo
yeah man last night had me [ __ ] crazy
i performed for some little weed party i
wasn't even ready i haven't performed in
mad long you know what i'm saying like
i've been on the show
every day every day honing the skill
i'm about to put a new album out
but rapping it's not that fun when it
becomes a business man when it was just
[ __ ] around and like chilling it was
amazing but it come to become fun when
you look at businesses fun oh yeah no
you doesn't but see for me that's not as
that's not my best business what's your
best business my best business is my
food stuff my you know my my other
endeavors
you know this is just for fun yeah well
that's good but it's it's also a big
part of my life so listen you know
everybody know you you're not gonna have
to [ __ ] i saw you before and i said
[ __ ] he lost like what i lost like 110
pounds i lost 130. and i'm still a
little fat
100 so i'm a fat [ __ ] bastard
no no i've been training listen never
say bad things about yourself you're
right but i you know sometimes i have to
shame myself
i better listen i know that whole saying
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know don't say that
you're conscious don't you know you're
self-conscious don't know you're joking
you're actually right about that they
don't know you javelin
they don't play games they don't go by
emotion they go by what you say they
don't say well i'm so sorry for myself i
hope i die oh you want to die
[ __ ] why don't you experience
this car accident no no yeah now i'm not
trying to speak that into existence
you're beautiful god said you beautiful
you're beautiful anybody else say [ __ ]
that's right they made more all
different sizes
my mama loves me
so let me matter
[Music]
this podcast is sponsored by our friends
at manscape the leading male grooming
the fourth generation performance
package absolutely changed the grooming
game with this refined body wash over
two million men worldwide trust manscape
for their shower time routine manscape
refined body wash smells so great fellas
and ladies love the signature scent when
you start the self-care routine with the
ultimate body wash you and your boys
will be so fresh and clean
then keep the grooming game going with
the rest of the performance package 4.0
with the mower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
and ball deodorant and crop reviver
tuner remember the lawnmower 4.0
features cutting edge ceramic blade with
advanced skin technology to reduce
accidents getting nick down there hurt
it's also waterproof so you can use it
right in the shower get 20 percent off
plus free shipping
go to manscape.com clash hopkins keep
your balls trimmed fresh and clean with
nasty say mike sent you
[Music]
your brothers and sisters just me man oh
this is me
you good both parents yeah but father
left early probably around 12.
was never really there you know he was
he worked that night
so he said you know what i'm saying
you know you know what if you know what
the man has to do they have to do what
they have to do but
and we have to do what we have to do and
then we realize it we shouldn't wanted
it yeah it wasn't even worth doing we
had to do it huh we should have been
where we needed to be yeah
but um it's not worse than someone that
has regrets
no hell no can't live with that [ __ ] i
grew up good though man with my albanian
grandparents and yeah
yeah
oh they're tough yeah the albanian
grandparents were there they held me
down mom everyone had all the cousins it
was a nice thing nice childhood i felt
good about it
i had all the nice rap music all the
[ __ ] sneakers i needed
queens flushing [ __ ] in the 90s
i know
all those guys from um the a-team back
then and everything i talked to supreme
periodically yeah how's he doing he's
doing one for good spirits that's good
you got to keep people in good spirits
man you don't want them going
going off the deep end well listen we're
going to go anywhere but let's just go
with dignity we're not gonna die let's
just do with dignity that's right that's
what it's all about i say to myself this
is what i say i i'm talking to god like
why do you allow me to be born when i
know well you know i'm gonna be afraid
to die
you know i say why is that and then
that's what um i was going through this
um my plant medicine yesterday and it
was just lsd and my little shroom
mix we had and um
it was his lady was telling me hey hey
you're schooling to death with dignity
you know part of the situation that's
what it's all about that's all this
psychic stuff this
mystic stuff and this swami stuff it's
all about preparing for death
you know because conscience most of us
are afraid of it
we're not in tune with uh
immortality
it's all very poetic
you know so
it's all very it's it's
all these sayings about life and [ __ ] it
touches you in a way you know we allow
it to touch it exactly that's what it is
some people don't touch at all well
that's the thing for me i feel like i'm
able to to understand it and and fully
grasp and grip it once
everyone can't hit me
listen i've been around but i'm 55 right
and i've been around people that don't
feel
you know good people but they don't feel
um empathy about people dying or feeling
hurting
nothing they could watch him die is
well is it self-centeredness or what is
it about them is just they're just numb
i just think it's some form of self-hate
and i think any form of killing is some
form of self-hate
you know any kind of it any kind of
because that's just
that's killing yourself yeah killing
what you are a human being
a humanity
you see [ __ ] psychedelics changes
lives
it really does it's like i would love it
makes you a totally different person i
used to be a brute a knock knob head oh
god did you ever think that you'd be
doing psychedelics hell no
hippie junkie waiting for the crackheads
yeah crackheads straight up like what
the [ __ ] is this
these guys do so much more than we did
we were [ __ ] behind i had the idea
they were [ __ ] behind
they're free in their mind you know like
that
this world is is definitely a place
where it could hold you down but if
you're free in the mind
there's nothing that could hold you
you're not you're doing giving that math
of yourself yeah if you're not a master
of yourself you're not free until you
become that then you're still in prison
you know self-imprisonment do you ever
think about what is this
every [ __ ] day what is this what's
going on why does why does the ocean
stop right there why can't all this
water is coming and that's make the
whole world why does it stop right there
it's [ __ ] trippy and why is life why
at any moment god can say kill all these
[ __ ] boom water just kill us or
why that doesn't happen
why why they haven't why the water
doesn't keep coming why does it stop
right there
the simple
scientifical answer to that
is the magnetic pull from the moon i
think that's a good one but so you tell
me the water is uh i don't know i'm just
gonna explain that because i saw that
big black hole every day seven miles i
saw that big black hole i'm saying whoa
yeah that's another world it's
something you couldn't even the father
have you been watching any of that
hundred-foot wave show you see that [ __ ]
nah i'm scared of [ __ ] that's what i've
said but you know there's some there's a
place in portugal called nazareth
and
there's a [ __ ] at least six seven
foot like seven mile
like ditch
that the wave hits and it becomes this
massive hundred foot [ __ ] break can
kill you
a [ __ ] three foot wave could kill you
i got spiked straight down in new jersey
i thought it was over
you know what i mean like this is
[ __ ] hundred foot in portugal but
forget that sometimes you fall off the
board goes down and come down
oh yeah now that knock your teeth in
your head and everything but when you
held down it's only like when you're in
water and you're being held down you
feel [ __ ] totally helpless all that
training goes out the window you're
panicking for your [ __ ] life hearth
beating yeah you can't even cry getting
nothing there's no there's no your tears
don't kind of
locks up
nah for real like it's just like you
have to just go numb and just let it
like you're suspended and just come up
i was in there with the shark and i had
that ironing suit that first the next
night you gotta get this off i was in
the chaos that [ __ ] wanted a
bite he was the iron suit in the [ __ ]
shade no no no he could have kicked me
and
[ __ ] yeah fished away somewhere
he's so big he's gonna grab me and just
bounce
the [ __ ] out of there oh man
yeah it's like all these different
creatures on earth and
the land the sea things that [ __ ]
crawl how do you understand some stuff
how do you how do you explain the fruit
fly you know what a fruit flies of
course they live for like three hours i
didn't know they lived for three hours
but i know they invest all kinds of
things the man lived for three hours the
women lived for five i believe
and they're born
and the men and impregnate the woman
and the women fly to a destination
and the men die boom but but before they
die the lights are flicking flicking so
they're partying
because they plant planted their seed
they celebrate boom the life thing boom
then normal like pile they're dead
and so for an hour later they're flying
to another location the women
and they flying they're getting this
muddy water to lay the eggs
and they're doing the same thing lights
are blinking blink of the status and so
grateful thanking god that they they the
eggs went into the
the precise place in the water and then
they die by
four hours of living
and if um and if that doesn't happen
the world's this is disrupted 100 yeah
there has to be a reason for that yeah
there's a there's a delicate balance
between everything in this world and
that has a purpose but i don't know what
the [ __ ] it is
if all of them die the whole planet died
right just
this fish died all the planets they've
all bugged out all the planets that if
all the people die the plant for the
planet flourish
because we're fungus we're fungus
everything is all fungus
we can smokers when we die and ride out
you can grab us and you smoke that's
what i want yeah
i'm always sad you better smoke me
you know then keith richards did that to
his father or something maybe i think so
yeah he did left them right yeah he
sniffed him
i'll [ __ ] around and do that that was
cool i respect that yeah
sniff or smoke it i i don't want to burn
i'd rather sniff it
let's have you put your you know you see
back in reverse in the sea that's your
time machine that's right going forward
with your father whoever i look at my
kids in my time machine they're going in
the future for me i see my children and
i [ __ ] i'm just like astonished like
you know it's like i can't believe like
what the hell is going on like
i remember being that now i'm watching
them do
the same things i did and act the same
way and you could tell the tantrums oh
yeah i used to do that [ __ ] yeah i used
to lay on the [ __ ] middle of the
floor
that's totally out of their mind um
[ __ ] special ed and everything say
that's me
he said that is me right dude especially
they don't belong especially this lady
don't want to work [ __ ] you fighting the
teacher so they're especially head
oh man
special that was a good time beautiful
right beautiful bunch of good people get
your milk and cookies
milk and cookies
the breakfast oh you got signed up for
the early breakfast is it this is what i
find so interesting people in brooklyn
are only people proud to be in this
special end i've never heard people that
was especially fms let people know
they're special that we don't even hey i
wasn't speculating we did this that's
right cooking the milk that's a good
that's a big accomplishment
yeah from special space after here right
look at that you know what i mean a
serious [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
just remembering like junior high school
and high school and just all that stuff
i'm scared to come to school because
somebody's gonna kick your ass
that's brooklyn okay i ain't going to
school today i'm staying outside i only
go to school for lunch lunchtime we get
the food to get out right there was
always something going on man yeah
it was always something [ __ ] crazy
well i finally keep you got five things
no if i anything i find i keep yeah
i ask somebody for a dollar every day yo
let me get a dollar please oh yo let me
get a dollar let me get a dollar always
for the [ __ ] i always borrow the dollar
from the same kid every day i must owe
that kid like 400
he kept it he left that a lot of money
he kept giving it yeah he kept giving it
to me he didn't care a lot of people
would ask him to borrow a dollar he was
that guy oh he's the one yeah he was the
one he was
he was definitely the one i was that guy
being picked on in school [ __ ] took my
glasses and put it in the gas tank of a
[ __ ] truck
just for not just me
yeah man
yeah that's not a nice [ __ ] thing
kids were [ __ ] leaning back getting
yeah
bullied for being fat
you need to call me fat [ __ ] money to
[ __ ] push you in the bush
i'm getting pushed in the bush i got
pushed in the bush several times they
may have some [ __ ] behind you
you just slapped me and now you're
running
i want to get off yeah let me get one
off now let me get a hit off baby you
gotta catch me yeah and you know i'm not
gonna catch you because i'm fat and i
can't [ __ ] catch you i know some fat
people fast the [ __ ] now now i
got some [ __ ] legs now i got some i
got some speed
i got some boost
you have any baby
yeah i got i got one brand new one
and i got a 16 and a 14 year old who's
14 the girl the guy the guy yeah yeah
name
elijah elijah i like your name my son
named um elijah too that's beautiful
morocco elijah tyson
elijah nain yeah the name character
elijah muhammad
i want i in my mind he's named after him
but
she named him after some [ __ ] in the
bible you have isaac in the bible yeah
in my mind it was named after elijah
muhammad i know we all love him and my
cousin's name is a good family named
naeem
i always love that name i like that name
as well it felt strong you know elijah
you know
elijah's a strong name
he's a good kid
he really plays ball
he knows he i feel like he could be a gm
you know he knows the game so he [ __ ]
blows my mind with the things he tells
me about
trading players and his
mindset of the you know it's just like
he's a little [ __ ] bugged out to here
he's kind of smarter than me well um
right it's a good thing
we hope so
we hope so we hope it's a good thing
sometimes people get too smart now
you're right you got to put them you got
to let them know
you're 14. don't [ __ ] think you know
everything though tell me about it tell
me about it i was thought to have
thought it was grown
and to find out i wasn't
those are those years you need to be
able to learn you know you have been
locked up
not a not an extended stay oh you feel
trippy yeah a little boom boom boom but
many times yeah i've been in every book
and
oh no this coast [ __ ] that coast
stupid [ __ ] though we don't do that no
more though no no no i stopped that
i stopped all that and he gets so many
chances that's what i mean i don't
really want to i don't like it's not fun
to be there
i should even for two nights three
nights shit's not fun period you know in
the movies and totally looks like it's
fun but they don't know you're not
you're not doing nothing but in the
[ __ ]
sometimes you don't even get um
physical people you get the machine
dropping your food off for real in some
[ __ ] machine yeah you don't see no
human being no people touching you it's
a machine come down
drop your food off you put it back in
trade goes
no contact it's crazy they [ __ ] spend
more on punishment in this
country country's all about punishment
it's all about punishment [ __ ] up all
about punishment there's no real
rehabilitation or like even the prior
debilitation yeah
no rehabilitation but even prior to that
they don't they don't spend the time on
the on the knowledge and helping people
you know grow
prior to the [ __ ] problems happening
well that might cost money it might cost
books yeah or computer [ __ ] yeah all
right
i don't want to get these for a free
um unestablished school that nobody
knows about and yeah if they play that
[ __ ] this is a scumbag game yeah but
you know just you gotta keep hope keep
hope is not gonna be this way forever
yeah
we've come a long way
humane society human beings came a long
way
when we bring when i bring into a you
know new life into this world i look
around and all the crazy [ __ ] that's
going on
it's like i almost feel like i feel
guilty you know like what am i setting
my child up for no listen um but it's
inevitable country that's that's just
you don't want to handle every step
responsibility because no matter what
time this is what it is we live we're
going to live life that's just how it is
you're right it's me trying to [ __ ]
yeah it's just so much johnny just
trying to run you're trying to run your
own show yeah you know it's all about
the baby we're not going to live long
but we're working for now that's right
putting everything in now
that's uh you know i let them know that
all the time that's this is
i gave up i'm done with me
i'm doing it for everybody else now
trying to set up the family that's a
good journey yeah for me i i
i'm i'm a minimalist i don't really need
a lot to be happy you know
i love i love a lot of things but when i
realize what i [ __ ] actually like
doing and what i do every day i wake up
i work out i eat i ride a bike [ __ ] else
i don't really need much else i could i
could watch fights and that's it you
know my life is you know people think my
life is so exciting but i do travel a
lot but my own trouble one thing i do is
i go out hang out with my my birds hang
out with my kids i go in my closet look
at my clothes i'm never wearing you know
i have clothes all night look at it like
me too
i haven't when i die i'm not gonna have
nothing but stuff
my clothes fits all i'm not gonna win
oh man yeah i'm a [ __ ] hoarder i'm a
hoarder of things i have closed 15 yet
the tags still on them wow they don't
know where i just
i have clothes i bring clothes i move
some place i we put them in storage i
don't go to that store for five years i
move somewhere and i don't know here now
i'm here and
then the guy the there's this polish
dude in my buildings dude mike who uh
i actually uh he i gave you a hat i sent
it to johnny it's a viola pigeon club
you know that place in brooklyn no it's
a it's like a bunch of people together
yeah but they do it on my roof in my my
studio building and
he just won 70 grand from you know he
raced this chinese dude dude had 90
birds he put 11.
and he [ __ ] won the most expensive
pigeon 1.9 million so i'm saying these
things are crazy they're gorgeous and
they're sorry i'm unbelievable
i've seen some serious ones you guys
haven't been only they didn't want to do
it
yeah you just want to get home fast
right this number is shot and walked
home
yo
that those birds are [ __ ] phenomenal
just seeing them when they when they
practice fly them just doing the circle
right above the building here's the
train we have to take it first we take
them
one mile then two miles and then three
more all until we get to 100.
it's you eat you go each step yeah
tomorrow
one mile another month two day
three every day that's dedication fun
dedicated to that yeah every day
that's beautiful
i always love that [ __ ]
these are all my life i don't even know
why i do it it's because it's it's in
you which is something that just came
through all my life i'm gonna have birth
even when i don't know why
that's what i just had for
birds
how does it feel to have a tiger though
was that like
if listen um you grew up with like he
grew up with you right yeah since a baby
yes and now you saw him
i miss having a tiger i'm sure but you
can't when you have little kids because
they get jealous
they don't want nobody to be around you
but dumb and all that bull the tiger
would hang out with all of us in here
you could be chuckling and he could
choke him
it's not like they just want to be one
person they don't really want to hang
out with anybody else it's pretty
unbelievable yeah i mean when you have
them since they're a baby that you're
you're the parent oh i sleep with them
yeah you're the you're the you're the
father i always sleep with my cat but
they start farting at night
you can't imagine that [ __ ] 700 pound
[ __ ] cat oh man you have to crack the
windows oh [ __ ]
you [ __ ] that it's in the door too why
are you let these [ __ ] in here
mike
and you can't get rid of it because it's
like farting pissing the [ __ ] stains
in the wall and the floor all the rug
hearted [ __ ]
so i got in their own house and i put
them in the house [ __ ] i bought the
house next door tonight made that their
house they got a lot of [ __ ] exotic
pets in the bronx like in the [ __ ]
projects when they were there it's
[ __ ] up right keep the alligators in
the crocodiles
listen the [ __ ] i'm telling you what
you're talking about the [ __ ] had a 500
pound tiger and had a goddamn alligator
in this bathtub and so the alligator in
the line got in a fight and this
[ __ ] in the apartment yeah black
muffler in the tub right in the tub and
there's one bedroom apartment two
bedroom apartments in the bar he had
them since they were a baby i don't know
how he snuck him in there but the the
alligator was in
the goddamn pool the the the the tub and
the cat staying there they started
fighting this guy this [ __ ]
what's in his mind a tiger an alligator
fighting he goes hey stop stop trying
he's trying to break it up like it's a
regular fight yeah
they put [ __ ] him up
they [ __ ] him up man
and then he's in new york and they're
looking at you got a what a 500 tiger
here alligator how did you do this is it
this guy
okay what is it 25 pound tiger living in
harlem listen
that could be another one
but listen oh that [ __ ] no yeah listen
wanna look at that that's look how big
that [ __ ] is holy [ __ ] go back
look at look at this
he's an apartment but that's a one
bedroom apartment building you could
smell them from downstairs oh my lord i
don't care how high he you can smell me
10th floor good thing he had the window
guards on there you know what i'm saying
because we can't drive this car these
are [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know
these things
that [ __ ] is crazy
where the [ __ ] did he get that man you
should get them from black market yeah
listen
blow your mind right in flushing somehow
right no there's more there's more
tigers and captivity there than the wow
that is [ __ ] mind-blowing
so when you see that tiger that is that
is is that a bengal tiger that's a
bangle okay so that is that one that
specific species almost extinct those
are the ones that they're not that many
in the wild the white bangles the white
bangles fig oh okay
and you had that one yeah you had that
one but some of them are pure white you
guys got um like gray stripes or
something you gotta yeah i don't know
what you did this white but you gotta
you gotta um shake it and see the
stripes oh [ __ ] the regular ones are
endangered of course they're beautiful
those are unbelievables like that that
animal he's ready to shoot and
tranquilize because he's ready to blast
him yeah see that's [ __ ] up he said he
laughed that's [ __ ] up he's been
blasting with the shoddy right there
that happened range that cat is so
scared they've never been in never seen
a person before other than his trainer
so they brought this club home at eight
weeks but look at the guy that had the
crocodile in the tiger fighting in the
in the tub
hopefully they didn't kill it
they [ __ ] hitler
apartment up there yeah it is that's the
harlow apartment that's ming
holy [ __ ] he's just chilling in the
living room like it's nothing that's not
cool man
[Music]
also when you have those crate like just
to have those [ __ ] crazy things that
are just
listen um from the wild wild like like
africa and amazon in the apartment
though
this room right here you have to chill
out there's not even enough we need this
room you ain't gonna having no one no
where does the tiger go to the bathroom
and think about he um
yeah probably in the sink not walking no
they probably they they ship it up and
flush it or take it out
oh well listen
i know when they [ __ ] in the house
everybody smells in the whole damn
apartments yeah this says this says that
the urine seeped through the ceiling
listen
underneath listen if they piss on you
right oh you just hella get off
because that's that maintenance and
everything that's an understanding your
paws and smell listen they walk by you
they rub it till you rub on you they
walk by and pile the tail over they'll
pop piss on you
hit you like a spray yeah like like
territorial no they're like pissing on
people
no they just want to piss me off
they do when they're in the cave i said
well i thought you got pissed
i just want to piss on you
that's wild
hey look up this young fighter called
the monster you ever hear monster no
japanese fighter called monks this is a
monster crazy crazy dude yeah let's
check them out man cookie what's his
name
yeah let's look at some of his fights
he's a mean fellow where's he fight in
the japanese 118 pounds but wow he was
like 108 boxing
he's the mean son of a [ __ ] oh yeah you
see this bad [ __ ]
you don't look like much he's he's
better than maddie pacquiao man pacquiao
is blue like that jeff is good
he looks like a [ __ ] pop star oh wait
till he get on these [ __ ]
the most efficient hunting machine in
all the boxing this is
the monster
that's a badass guy he'd be too broke
him down ooh
118 yeah who the hell fighting that that
[ __ ] division weights yeah but who
some bad mothers yeah yeah some killers
oh break them ooh the monster he beat
him so easy
oh i love it
the monster
it's a good piece right yeah hell yeah
it gave me goosebumps
[ __ ] monster he's a mean little [ __ ]
tell me what else you want to do though
i don't know what else you gotta do
everything in life man like what
everything i don't even know like i just
lived there by making movies yeah that
for sure i've been in a couple of movies
but
i l i love producing my own [ __ ] and
making my own things i i do a show
called [ __ ] that's delicious huh what
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that's delicious it's
been my show for over six years now
let's check it out traveling around the
world eating all kinds of different
foods experiencing culture
it's been beautiful we've been like 70
episodes let's check one out
whoa look at me harry went right the
fawns the fawns right there he saw me
right there on fairfax
and i was in decent shape there for what
i thought
terrible
i'm so bad but you're doing something
about it now you're right nothing about
it is not terrible oh terrible you're
not doing something about it
so i pretty much brought my friends with
me all over the world and we just
[ __ ] ate chilled
smoked weed
got drunk
fornicated you know what i mean
that's the perfect left the people
that's what i'm saying
that's what i thought i was like man
this is the perfect life i want to live
sometimes it's hard to get up when
you're living right you're right you're
right when i first started fighting i
became champ i used to always
i couldn't stop drinking
i was a wreck
just destroyed myself drinking it's
destroyed myself
you know for some reason
and i was never a big drinker
i like i like natural wine i like to
drink wine because it makes me feel like
i'm high you know it's more like that
type of
never been like a thing for me but man i
[ __ ] od on food
well that's a form of self you know self
uh loathing
no it's not and over indulgence and
that's not
you don't think so no because um you can
take you eat when you're happy huh you
eat when you're happy
i don't know when i eat that's the thing
i eat all the time it's a [ __ ] whether
it's a celebration whether i'm
upset whether it's like i'm kind of i'm
a cat i'm like um calorie counter oh
yeah yeah
is that how you did it if i don't if um
if i don't work out i won't eat
i i i have to i have to justify certain
things i eat by working out also hey
about mr sandville get my workout i'm
not gonna eat i'm gonna go gorgeous yeah
not like i like i have to get my work in
today sundays are not definitely not a
day off you know day the day off you can
do some work yeah no day i haven't taken
a day off in a long time
[ __ ] that
24 hour work man
24 hour on the clock that's right
it's not enough [ __ ] time oh no i
have to disagree there's enough time but
you just know how to um i'm not good at
organizational and like we have to the
left is all about the yi and the yang
the the polarity
you know i have to balance balance
i'm working at it we all are yeah all
our brothers work in progress man
and we're going to kind of constantly be
a work in progress and
till we die
some progress
becoming better
more compassionate more
caring
growing
just comes with life so what what is
this voice land with the sheep
that [ __ ] that was the channel it was on
about a while back that's the donkeys
protecting the sheep that's that's
actually this beautiful uh this farm in
in oregon
in brownsville oregon brownsville
straight up that's what it was called
and uh we had amazing lamb there
got to see the sheep they don't let you
[ __ ] with them because somehow it ruins
the meat yeah you know when you when you
[ __ ] with yeah they get panicked yeah
exactly
so you
just let them chill
but yeah you've been all over the world
japan friends this that
it's like it was a beautiful time
i continue to do this on my youtube
channel also it's been i just keep it
more local now
i just did a little festival in brooklyn
the other day in south side in
williamsburg yeah had a bunch of people
come out made fried pizzas and [ __ ]
cannolis and [ __ ] for the people
played all kinds
it's too many calories damn cannoli i
know
but that's good sugar damn sugar if
that's the only thing you eat all day
and then you do the bridge three times
it's all right
that's how i justify it he worked the
bread and i run it yeah
i'm biking it i'm running it i'm trying
to do a run bike swim but i can't find a
place to stay i'm just jumping in the
[ __ ] room
like i like being in the water when it's
really cold really i like taking cold
showers as well you should come in the
ocean one time when it's like december
put a wetsuit on it's just [ __ ] like
that
the shark show and it was it was one of
the times i was practicing there yeah i
was practicing how [ __ ] good did that
feel it was wonderful
i couldn't really feel the suit on yeah
exactly but you get the face you feel it
in the face yeah it was pretty good a
lot of people out there too nicole yeah
with nothing on it's a thing not the
thing
the polar bear club east coast east
coast surf it all happens in the winter
time everything hmm
cody alex excuse me
coney island was a good time
nathan
bro the big whale the show yeah the big
will a lot i mean
you know coney island yeah yeah is the
tower still up where are they supposed
to be i'm gonna jump these are
parachutes yeah the parachute
somebody you know why something it
didn't open up before and that's why i
closed it
you know he had something happen you
know that happened why would they stop
it
but they took the cyclone down right
i think it burned
yeah um
coney island's not really too safe these
days
it's nice it's it was a good time at one
point you gotta venture out
go to another part another boardwalk
and where is that california radio drive
that's right
out here something else
special out here
it's very interesting trust me there's
everybody from all parts of the world
come here i'm trying to i'm trying to
make a move but i don't know i just
can't get out of the city why would you
want to go anywhere else
that's the thing i don't if if you were
to go anywhere
i would say vegas vegas is the best
place to go you're gonna get um
twice your money for what you're gonna
pay here and it's gonna be top dollar
and it's all about bang for the buck at
this point man i'm [ __ ] getting
demolished in taxes in new york that's
why you gotta go to vegas
everybody go to me get a house in vegas
chill out
get a house here live certain amount of
time i guess enjoy life a lifetime you
know life basis my wife is just
she everywhere she goes she buys
property she is
ecliptic she that's all she does that's
fine that's just what she does
i had to get my wife into that come on
baby
please get into the real estate business
for god's sakes mm-hmm
listen
god ain't making any more so
you know you gotta get as much as you
can right
it's getting taken up quick too
oh smaller and smaller yeah the method
of knocking them from the booth the
chinese they buy everything
they bought up all of vancouver all the
africa too yeah
they know what they're doing
nothing's nothing stupid about those
gentlemen
let's see which which one is this white
bronco white bronco oh nice well that's
right i mean you know it's so subjective
i like to light the palo santo and have
a sound bath
you know what i mean
sound bath calms me
opens the chakras
it looks pretty sexy here you feel me
you wanna do songs with
i don't [ __ ] i don't like anybody oh
god i do i mean you know i've done songs
with so many different people i just
focus on myself i hear you
for me this is like i can't be waiting
on people
it's art i can dig it you gotta be done
when it's cold
when it's going and when it's calling me
i gotta do it
though your head's cutting all those
tattoos up there mm-hmm
that was a good time it was fun times
man that's what i'm saying a fun time to
get the compounds when i have fun
that's all that really matters
i don't like i don't like creating [ __ ]
with pressure
i like when there's it's just flows you
know it's just
it's natural
and no effort yeah for real i mean
it's not it's not a it's not a visible
effort it's it's an effort but it's not
like
it's not like a you know what i'm saying
it's not forced effort no it's just um
it comes naturally exactly
same thing with a fight it comes now you
don't know that the second nation got a
thing that's really what it is it's a
dance it's a it's it's a it's it's the
way your heart beats honestly that's
really what it is rhythm it's rhythm
it's electrical it's for real it's
exactly everybody has the rhythm you
know different rhythm everybody has a
rhythm every animal every person
has rhythm
i was watching something and this dude
he was like a
classically trained musician he had a
heart like he had a pacemaker put in or
he had some sort of heart thing going on
and he didn't [ __ ] play the same
afterwards
he didn't play the same because you know
the heart it was like different rhythm
it happened you know
you know um
in the in the avocado with the police
was named that place
but you know there was where they had to
orca whales that
see oh and see where yeah and that's why
they didn't know that they were
attacking each other the alcohols they
speak different languages in certain
parts of the world
and i can't believe they are
understanding each other how [ __ ]
crazy is that i didn't know that
wow it's one from russia the other one
from the antarctic they may not speak
the same language that's
that's [ __ ] that's mind-blowing right
there i didn't know that speak different
languages
whales
yeah we're looking at black fish
yeah yeah and i didn't know but i'm
watching they say
whales from different part of the world
don't speak the same language speak
different language i blow my mind
after they all understand everybody
knows what's going on now
that's a very very smart
animal
oh man that mammal is a [ __ ] genius
the killer whale is this the king of the
ocean 100 percent they kill a well no
longer tactical skills right
like to have the mind to play certain
games and do trickery
you see when they trick you when they
grab those big sperm wells yeah the
babies are twice the size world they put
their heads on their hoes they try to
suffocate them
they put their hands on and try to
suffocate them because the baby's so
much bigger than the the um
the walker yeah but just the baby's
trying to get him can't hold them
they're so big those sperm wells baby
their monster baby down there the whole
room
to make something that [ __ ] massive
man
my god you know there's a
god because either what does he what
does he belong well it's like a platypus
what the hell is he so big what is he
doing here it's a relation to the
platypus right no but i'm just saying
it's like that why they're so big why is
it so [ __ ] massive crazy and they're
probably um animals seven miles down
that's bigger than that for sure they
eat the whales gruesome looking look at
that [ __ ] thing
wow
it's just a face
that's good meat though um the orcas
like eating those guys
i had well before excuse me i had well
before how'd that taste didn't taste
great
it tastes like a [ __ ] wet mushroom
oh no i was in alaska and you know
with the people they you know they they
show you their culture you had to taste
it so what they [ __ ] do is they dip
whale blubber into seal oil
[ __ ] seal oil smell like straight up
[ __ ] [ __ ] cheese like
i got on my shirt and i had to throw the
shirt away i just kept smelling what the
[ __ ] smells like [ __ ]
like someone sat on my chest
then girl you don't use that no yeah you
know
hey all my stuff is coming down now you
know
christmas
i'm telling you i love you kiki i love
you
i'm going nuts kiki wake up
that caught that that feeling that like
that chillness afterwards like freezing
my balls off right yeah that's
phenomenal
holy [ __ ] they had to put the heel in
the clock on me i was freezing you have
a coat on and you take stronger when
they wear off god damn
like siberia out there
why is that i don't know i think the
defense mechanisms drop or something
it's like it's like it's an acceptance
of some sort of like something at least
you're accepting something
90 degrees up then i'm freezing my ass
off
that's what this rooms do to you buddy
i'm gonna have to take some this week
what are you doing today i'm gonna go
work out
we're gonna have a nice meal go on a
little hike that's what i've been trying
to do i'm trying to go on a little hike
in the daytime doing the daytime daytime
hiking everything looks good yeah do a
show it's beautiful
just gotta be on point just case when
i'm [ __ ] mountain lions come out they
will come out they will right yeah
they're there they will try they will
they will try they will try they're not
going to back up they're going to try it
damn
they're mean too
yeah it's cougars yeah they're saying
like
their hands in your hair
oh no they're gonna bite you you're
gonna try to stop another scratch and
bite you oh oh man it'll be on your ass
so bad you're saying oh [ __ ] they're
like throwing these crabs yeah biting
they're scratching that's some nasty
monsters they don't [ __ ] they don't
let go right or they will they're just
keeping it unless you can you're fast
they're faster than dog they will cut
you the shreds
cougars why can't they just [ __ ] make
an easy hike like why why did it have to
be the [ __ ] deadly without struggle
there's no progress
you've enlightened me once again yeah
yeah
you straight up man you [ __ ] ass man
like yeah guys you're right gotta go
with the wolves yeah you're right you
gotta send yourself there so what is
this right here these rooms or something
i [ __ ] took the edibles on the plane
over here i had no idea where i was for
five hours
i took like 300 milligrams over
i didn't know i was flying or [ __ ]
sitting still
we don't [ __ ] around either man baby um
how many um
insurance we do
last night
well not last night normally when we do
the show
um you know
that'll have me [ __ ] that'll have my
jaw moving
apart me that's right
i don't know what last night was i
hadn't slept for 40 hours
and to have this much energy you're
[ __ ] this this is sick
i feel like that [ __ ] in me baby
i'm getting that plan but i got the late
flight tonight
we're going to antigua tomorrow in china
and chiba yeah nice
they have property over there we want to
have some um you know some
what's those things
edm's edm party yeah we want to have
those guys come down there like a [ __ ]
like dance music
oh yeah like dance music yeah edm music
yeah yeah yeah
that's true it's doing all around the
world
no [ __ ]
past wow well when you uh you know when
you're on when you're on the goods
when you're on mushrooms and the edm hit
you it's like the [ __ ] and then the
world explodes yeah the world's gonna
show some interesting people there i
think that's dressed up like in tutus
electric [ __ ] neon colors yeah
yeah that's how they dress up they're
just like [ __ ] babies and
it's pretty super safe
yeah everybody said what we're gonna do
i want you to do this brother
one thing i want you to look at these
people there's a couple
a couple of
tens of millions of people here right
tell them something tell them who you
are tell them what you're about
this is your boy bach levi flushing
queens native
100
new york city
this man right here
you don't even have to speak about what
this man represents and what he's meant
to so many different people around the
world in life
grown up
with entertainment and
and knowledge and love
me
i'm about
prosperity
progress
and becoming a better human being and a
better me that's all we can do in life
flushing queens
you know what i mean that's really
that's really all i can say i love so
many things
i hate a couple i'm trying not to
anymore
you feel me
just work in progress
well that's what i'm trying to get you
you're very enlightened and yeah i've i
could tell that you've
you know
you've done a lot of inner studies
i need more of that
it's gotta love yourself i think i do
i'm gonna stop putting myself down also
yeah don't do that you can't listen i'm
telling you conscience don't know you
playing or not because you walk you are
what you say you are you never ever like
put yourself down before beforehand all
the time i do it but then you kind of
you exceed your expectation and it feels
better because i say to myself who else
gonna tell me i gotta check me check
yourself you know what i mean who's
gonna say mikey stupid [ __ ]
no one's gonna say that i'm gotta say
that that's the only reason i say that
because no one's gonna tell me that so i
have to say to myself i'm not a [ __ ]
clown i know i'm being a dick of course
people don't tell me that so i have to
tell myself that yeah keeping yourself
in check is yes exactly if you don't do
no self-evaluation you ain't nobody
i've always feel like i you know i'm
very aware and i'm conscious of when i'm
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
when i feel like you know like i fee i'm
i'm very
i'm aware like if i [ __ ] up i'm
apologizing i have no bones about it bro
i'm i'm sorry you know i'm an inventory
guy like the end of the day i say that
that was that nice to that person but i
polite to him did i get too aggressive
but i always do inventory
so i could be better than i was the next
day do you ever make a men's voice you
just so no let bygones be by guns do
people make a man no like feel if you
say you've you maybe i [ __ ] treated
this person wrong would you reach out at
some point or no absolutely yeah you do
i always say brother remember last night
i said something i i thought it came
that came across disrespectful to me and
i just want you to know i'm sorry i
always put myself in check
i do that too i feel like it's necessary
people respect that [ __ ] now it's not
it's more about me being able to
assess that situation and [ __ ] fix it
for myself and just all about um
getting in check your insecurities we
all have insecurities we're all the same
we just have different habits you know
but um we're all the same we all work
the same
and
i'm gonna let you go i'm here my man
action bronson and hopefully you come
back again and hang out with me brother
[ __ ] this beautiful [ __ ] i love you
man beautiful i'm serious
actually [ __ ] bronzer
[Music]
you